we still haven't talked about the
biggest story that no one's talking
about
then you got to come back
what is it
where the hell is flying up in the sky
that no one knows
what they are that that to me i
understand yeah
we
one was in europe one was in california
took pictures of the same thing at the
same time the government admits we don't
know what these things are they're not
our technology they're not any other
known technology they are russian assets
no no they're not they're russian assets
i wish
you know what it'd be it'd be less
frightening if they were right because
they violate the fundamental laws of
physics yeah and we don't know what they
are it's the biggest story and everyone
just kind of collectively went ah
yeah
like why isn't this something we talk
about every day like there are things
that violate our airspace
get closest to our most technologically
advanced aircraft and naval you know
equipment and personnel the things that
are guarding our shores
and we go
i don't know what they are i don't know
how they got there i don't know how to
stop them
it's terrifying i agree so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you